Swing to dinner with your 8 person swing table,
After you break out your vintage baseball
glove leather wallet.
Because it's episode 38 of LÜT.
Start your day using some perfectly shaved
soap courtesy of the soap shaver.
And guys look your best thanks to the ABC's
of Men's Fashion book.
Maybe you could add this portable pocket hoodie
that attaches to any shirt to complete your
fresh look.
But if a hoodie isn't enough to protect you
from the elements you could wear a lion...
ski mask.
Which will winterize your face while you ride
on this gas-powered snowboard.
It holds up to 250 pounds and tops out at
18 mph.
For something a little less adventurous and
a lot more little fly the world's smallest
quadcopter.
The Proto X is less than 2 by 2 inches and
weighs four tenths of an ounce.
You could always blow up your arm with this
inflatable mini gun arm.
After that you'll want to take a few laps
while you nap in your pool...bed.
And gaze at your glorious candelier made up
of 15,000 hand strung acrylic gummy bears.
Or look at your Sparkbeats phone case that
lights up using the flash from your phone's
camera.
So you have enough light to read K is for
Knifeball.
An alphabet of terrible advice book including
"D is for drifter", "G is for grandma", and
"A is for apple."
Eat one every day and wash it down with your
Mom's cabernet.
Break the rules and cheat with this apron
cooking guide that helps with cooking times,
how to properly cook steaks, and even a spaghetti
measuring guide.
Luckily you have a leaning tower of pasta
to keep that in.
And a squirrel nut grinder that is a grate
little rodent.
Equally great is this condiment gun that you
might want to use to add some flavor to your...
Bizarre food dot com.
A cool website where you can buy all kinds
of weird foods from giant bug chili dipping
paste to Chinese yellow scorpion candy lollipops
which you'll wash down with some giant centipede
whiskey to wash it down
That can carry in this shot flask that has
a shot glass built-in.
To add some fizz to that whiskey get a portable
water carbonator that turns still water into
a bubbly delight in less than three minutes.
But if that's too much work just steal someone
else's drink with Wave.
A toy that transfers liquids using the physics
of a syphon.
If your drinks too warm use the spin chill
to cool it down.
Simply attach it to the top of your container,
place it in ice, and spin.
Check your mail when you see this webmail
notifier light up and hopefully get a nicer
message than you'll find in these Misfortune
Cookies.
Don't listen to the cookies listen like an
audiophile using Meze headphones.
They're handcrafted out of ebony wood to reproduce
a warm natural sound.
Whether with the earbuds or these headphones
featuring a fancy ergonomic headband.
Really cute Robot Cleaner from Japan.
For something cute and squishy for your sweetheart
get squishables.
The adorable squishable creatures feature
custom designs you can vote on to produce
the next squishy hedgehog or comfort food
toast.
Then get comfy with this blanket featuring
built-in speakers to listen to love songs
as you cuddle up in your tranquility pod.
The memory foam waterbed has 50 LEDs that
synchronize with your heart beat and it only
costs 30 thousand dollars.
If that's too extravagant keep warm with these
love gloves because you're probably smitten...
Finally, make sure to save up for full scale
Space shuttle orbiter replica that costs 3.5
MILLION dollars.
And as always...
thanks for watching